when you get youtube stars right yeah
exactly a right I went down a little
tape rabbit hole the other day you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Jamie told me about little thing so I
went down this crazy rabbit hole then I
read this Jezebel article about another
writer who went down a little tear abbot
hall and so I went down that rabbit hole
oh my god wait who's a little - a little
Tay is a nine-year-old girl who is
famous now on the internet for talking
[ __ ] and showing all the money she has
another thing she buys you don't know
about no no this is the death of society
okay little tase the death of society
lil little tang can we see you now yes
for sure
Oh me little toy the youngest flexor of
the flexor of the century who makes cash
me outside girl look like a scholar
she's [ __ ] nine dude okay I have a
nine-year-old all right this is crazy
play it played this video Jamie so he
can understand what little days all
about that's her revving up her
Lamborghini she gets out
[Music]
Jake pause
[Applause]
Tom Jake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen the next president
United States and he's bowing in the
background I mean this is what we're
doing we're doing this makes honey boo
boo look like Marie Curie let's get
three hundred thirty-seven thousand
likes
god dammit Jamie what have you done we
are stuntin on all y'all broke ass
haters 500k in cash and this Lambo cost
more than your college tuition I'm nine
and I ain't got no license
apparently all our shits rented okay you
know I'm embarrassed to admit this but I
would watch this over reading my own
articles so what the [ __ ] I might as
well just give up now